yo I'm Luke Cage don't test me
you know where to find me
everybody talking about Luke Cage like
he's Jesus I know Joe I just elect Mike
smoke bulletproof black man for the Hard
Rock's is a ghetto boogeyman of their
nightmare you can get a snack with this
really guys I don't know we try it man I
know community you can't keep doing what
you're doing I have no idea what you're
talking about
and believe me Luke Cage is nothing but
a man
eylem is mine damn hate to see such a
positive brother like Luke age go down
like that
you hurts you you're not invulnerable
Luke anyone who can take you on bare and
it can't be good for Harlem
I gotta find fish monster what makes
them so scary you hope you never have to
find out
[Music]
it's a Bushmaster they don't come
I've seen you raw but never burger
sometimes pretending to get [ __ ] done
[Music]
own doesn't need a hero it bees a queen
the darkness that you deal with every
day
we can't conceal them to hold it
don't let
just to be clear a lot in the market for
a psychic says you're not my sidekick me
it's my show hey everybody its charlie
they just dropped the Luke Cage season 2
trailer so let's break it down we got a
whole bunch of stuff happening they
tease some stuff in here there's some
stuff that they did not include in this
either especially the Iron Fist
crossover they've also been a lot of
questions about Netflix Avengers
crossover because of an infinity war so
I'll try to explain the infinity war of
it all because of the way they
incorporated the Battle of New York
during that first Avengers film during
the first couple of seasons of the
Netflix shows so all this Luke Cage
first then I'll talk about the infinity
war stuff at the end of the video if
you're finding me for the first time be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos
like the trailer says this is dropping
June 22nd right before Comic Con so if
you guys didn't know Iron Fist is legit
crossing over with Luke Cage season 2
there will be some Heroes for Hire
action and I think based on the action
of the trailer in the way they're using
the villain bushmaster I have a pretty
good idea of how they're gonna use the
Iron Fist character because what it
looks like is going on here is is the
bush master knows capoeira and he can
hurt Luke Cage Luke Cage does not know
martial arts he's literally been a
walking tank this whole time so he
hasn't had to learn any special martial
arts fighting skills like iron fist or
daredevil or some of the less powered
heroes so the minute you put him up
against someone that has similar powers
to him who does know martial arts he's
gonna get his ass handed to him
so the behind-the-scenes pictures of
Luke Cage and iron fist seem like it's
iron fist teaching Luke Cage how to
defend himself using some form of
martial arts but the biggest question in
far and away after this trailer dropped
is who the hell is Bushmaster who's this
villain character they're introducing so
Bushmaster if you couldn't tell is
definitely the season 2 villain I'm sure
there'll be a lot of other minor bosses
that he'll have to fight but Bushmaster
is meant to be the main antagonist now
mariah is back shades is back
Harlem's paradise is back like you even
see Luke cage fighting Bushmaster inside
Harlem's paradise so it seems like
there's this war for Harlem that
continues to be waged Bushmaster may
come to try and claim his stay clay
it looks like he has this gang behind
him here so maybe he becomes a drug
dealer and tries to set up a ring that
Luke Cage tries to bust but on the other
side of that you still have Mariah who
feels like Harlem needs a queen so like
you see her burning that building down
with shades they're still very active in
what's going on in the background she's
a little more insidious like she has her
tendrils and more aspects of the
business of Harlem so she's more of like
the kingpin type villain and I know a
lot of you are asking about daredevil
too what I'm hoping is is at the end of
Luke Cage like episode 13 they dropped
that first teaser for daredevil season 3
because that's gonna be the next Marvel
series that Netflix drops because this
is happening so close to comic-con I'm
expecting more daredevil season 3
footage at Comic Con like they'll drop
an actual trailer for it and a release
date so we'll find out what's going on
with that series and then if you didn't
know they are also shooting iron fist
season 2 I think they may have even
finished shooting it but that's not
gonna be released till next year so just
to go a little deeper on bushmaster I
know it seems like there's some magic
that he's weaving here inside this
circle but really in the comics what it
is is that he goes to Noah Bornstein the
person that gave Luke Cage his powers we
saw that play out during season 1 he
goes to that guy and forces him to give
him the same treatment that he gave to
Luke Cage another mutated version of the
Super Soldier Serum so his powers are
very similar but I don't know if the TV
show is gonna do that exact same
backstory there might be a couple of
tweaks to that but for the most part his
power level is almost exactly the same
as luke cage's but I think part of the
reason why they picked him specifically
as a villain is because one he knows
martial arts and he was an Iron Fist
villain in the comics too and you're
gonna have a little bit of iron fist
during Luke Cage season 2 so you have a
crossover villain for a crossover series
we'll see what he feels like compared to
cottonmouth last season because he's
like the benchmark for Luke Cage
villains cottonmouth was probably one of
the best characters from season one
everybody was super bummed out when they
killed him halfway through the season
hopefully they learned their lesson
after season one they corrected some of
the narrative and pacing problems which
I think you know helps because they have
misty night with her bionic arm
thank you very much iron fist remember
iron fist is a billionaire he owned that
hospital that misty Knight was in so it
was just a matter of time before they
start using
that money to help beef up the other
defenders characters obviously you have
the bobby fish character doing all that
voiceover telling Luke Cage that he
can't defend Harlem by himself like I
know it sounds kind of weird the
voiceover at the beginning because it
seems like it's meant to be sinister but
really it's just bobby fish trying to
get Luke Cage to realize that he can't
hold the entire city on his shoulders
they actually have a poster for season
two and it's literally him doing his
Atlas thing trying to carry the city on
his back so it sounds like just based on
the flow of this trailer if this is
relatively chronological that Luke Cage
is getting his Heroes for Hire staying
on by himself like he has that kid
shooting the commercial for him
absolutely hilarious he's riding high
you like you see him strutting his stuff
down the street all the women turn
around to look at him yeah yeah it's
really funny but then bushmaster just
walks up and they do that YouTube thing
where somebody catches him getting his
ass beat by bushmaster in the clip goes
viral and everyone's like damn no idea
which episode he debuts in but that just
sounds like it's gonna be the wake-up
call for him to start letting other
people help him out and then they have
that funny moment with misty night where
he's like you know I don't need a
sidekick and then she's like maybe I'm
not the one that's gonna be the sidekick
in this situation then he breaks the
fourth wall
Deadpool style and says you know this is
my show right like you talking about the
actual Netflix series because his name
Luke Cage is literally in the title of
the show so it feels like all the jokes
are poppin the characters look great I'm
really interested to see which other
characters get to crossover and how they
sort of flow this into daredevil season
3 because Jessica Jones kind of existed
by itself it was kind of a bummer too I
mean like there were a couple great
moments but for the most part she was
kind of off doing her own thing so I
don't want to give away spoilers for
that because there were not a lot of
people that watch my Jessica Jones
videos so I'm guessing we're rolling
into Luke Cage and daredevil with a lot
of people just having no idea what's
going on with her character but I don't
think that she's going to pop up I think
if anybody else pops up besides iron
fist it's gonna be Colleen wing because
she sort of comes hand in hand with iron
fist wherever he goes I don't think that
Luke Cage season 2 is gonna get into any
like super over defenders plot I think
it's gonna be largely self-contained and
it is just tee up some elements that the
pay off during daredevil getting into
the infinity war of it all what will
probably happen is is that they'll just
use it exactly the same way they use the
Battle of New York
they'll probably reference it as aliens
coming from outer space like some funny
twist on the idea like somebody on
street level imagine how a casual person
would refer to Squidward in Co obsidian
coming down to the sanctum they'll
probably use that for some comedy then
they'll talk about Wakanda just expect
Luke Cage to reference Black Panther at
some point it would be irresponsible if
they didn't have some fun with that
they're literally building outreach
centers in Oakland in New York City all
the places that there are Doctor Strange
sanctums and probably even more places
around the world the infinity war
directors did say that they considered
using the TV characters legit like
actually having mike colter and
daredevil show up during infinity war
but it got so out of control that they
had to exclude Hawkeye ant-man and the
wasp just because there were too many
characters so I've already done a bunch
of daredevil season 3 videos you can
click here to learn more about what's
going on during that and you can click
here for brand new Thor infinity war
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight